let's go next to oh I don't know why
don't we go to Chris from Texas Chris
you're on the air
pleasure
so I guess one thing I'm just kind of a
little scared about is like
there's been just an increase in white
supremacist violent and rhetoric
throughout this whole country like we
saw in 2018 with the Pittsburgh
synagogue shooting then we saw it again
in 2019 with the El Paso shooting in The
Poets synagogue shooting and now just
recently with this Buffalo shooting I
just feel like we have to do something
about it I feel like we have to take
more measures like against like the news
media that's responsible for like such
as Fox news about these things when you
say we have to take action what would
you do to Fox News
I feel like we need to I mean one thing
I'm thinking about doing is we would
probably need to maybe try to pressure
their sponsors to probably cut off ties
to people such as Tucker Carlson because
I feel like as long as Tucker Carlson
still gets money from Fox News and he
brings in a lot of the money since he's
like the highest rating person there
there's not gonna be much incentive for
Fox News to change well what you have to
remember we actually talked about this
earlier this week Fox is different than
some of the other networks and that fox
gets two-thirds of its revenue from
subscription fees from cable companies
and uh not so much from advertising so
actually going after Fox's advertisers
doesn't have as big of an effect as it
would on some other companies that's
other channels which is an unfortunate
thing so really what people have to do
is you have to call your cable company
and say I don't want Fox News make Fox
an optional Channel and if I don't want
it I save my two bucks a month that
would actually Crush Fox
kind of like what we do with oan with
the whole ATT Scandal that they had in a
sense but the difference is that fox is
included in just standard Cable packages
and people don't even realize that close
to two dollars a month from what they
pay is going to Fox even if you don't
watch it that happens
hello
all right thank you very much for the
call sounds like we're having a bit of a
connection issue but yeah that's the
issue with going after Fox's advertisers
they're not nearly as reliant on
advertisers as many of the other uh
platforms
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
One Stop Shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price little spoon makes
everything fresh just like homemade but
it's delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop it in the fridge or freezer
and it is ready when you are they have
100 organic cold pressed baby food for
every eating stage awesome food for
toddlers and for kids they even just
launched a new line of on the go
smoothies that kids love everything is
nutritionally balanced no junk food but
it is kid approved it's food that
they'll actually eat and enjoy and you
can't beat the prices with kids meals
under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my my audience
fifty percent off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below